bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver à la une de ça vous regarde ce
soir l'ordre du barreau au gouvernement
eric dupond moretti a pris ses fonctions
au ministère de la justice bête noire
des magistrats il se pose en garde des
sceaux du dialogue promet de ne faire la
guerre à personne sa feuille de route
est très ambitieuse la réforme du
parquet rien que ça oui mais laquelle
dupond moretti à la chancellerie coup de
génie coup de poker ou coup de folie on
en parle ce soir dans notre grand débat
on parlera aussi de la 5g et de cette
fronde qui monte chez les écologistes et
les associations de citoyens la nouvelle
génération de téléphonie suscite une
véritable levée de boucliers inutile
polluantes mauvaise pour la santé on
essaiera de démêler le vrai du faux et
de mieux comprendre aussi des enjeux
géostratégiques qui se cache derrière
cette nouvelle technologie chinoise
enfin plus âgés plus féminin plus à
droite
la nouvelle équipe gouvernementale
pilotée par jean castex inspire-t-elle
vos députés réponse tout à l'heure avec
comme à des frais dans ma journée à
l'assemblée voilà donc pour le programme
c'est parti hashed accès vers n'oubliez
pas de lire
il
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
regardez cette petite pépite dénichée
dans les archives des l'cie par un de
nos confrères de thé arlette gruss au
sire vous proposer un poste de ministre
de la justice ou l'accepteriez sur wii
sur wii vous le signe ouais bon personne
ne me le propose en ce sera un bordel
mais alors voilà ce serait un bordel
mais alors archives qui date d'avril
2010 8 est ce que ce sera le bordel on
va se poser la question ce soir
manifestement eric dupond moretti a
changé d'habits
premier déplacement vous allez le voir
ce soir à la prison de fresnes aux côtés
des personnels pénitentiaires dans les
habits de garde des sceaux l'avocat vous
acquittement spectaculaire et au
franc-parler tonitruant vous le voyez
sur ces images et bien à frapper fort
dès son premier discours d'arrivée la
place vendôme on en parle avec vous ce
soir didier parisse bonsoir vous êtes
magistrat j'ai envie de dire avant
députés parce que c'est aux magistrats
que je vais m'adresser ce soir mais vous
êtes aussi député la république en
marche de côte-d'or tout comme vous
georges fenech ancien juge d'instruction
longtemps député les républicains ici
même à l'assemblée nationale est
aujourd'hui à la tête d'une société de
conseils destinés à former des élus à la
lutte contre la radicalisation enfin
bienvenue à vous à valérie de senneville
vous êtes journaliste judiciaire aux
échos vous avez portraituré de
nombreuses fois eric dupond moretti et
on essaiera de comprendre un petit peu
avec vous comment cette personnalité si
tonitruante peu bousculé jusqu'où la
chancellerie je vous donne la parole
dans un instant mais celui qui va nous
présenter les décors c'est évidemment
stéphane blakowski comme tous les soirs
si j'ai bien compris
l'ombre d'un ancien président a plané
jusqu'au dernier moment
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane europe pour le micro ce
que je voyais si j'ai bien compris ce
soir si j'ai bien compris myriam le
président macron serait devenu un pantin
dont les ficelles sont tirées dans
l'ombre par nicolas sarkozy qu'est ce
qui vous fait dire ça précise au courant
c'est parce que c'est marqué dans tous
les journaux semaine alors là
franchement faut pas lire la presse on
ouvre médias parlent bien sûr ils sont
de parti pris sur sarkozy mais vous
voyez ils sont très claires sarkozy est
carrément devenu président puisque c'est
lui qui aurait composé le gouvernement
enfin l'aube ce qui est un magazine de
gauche plus modérée de gauche bourgeoise
à la même thèse que mediapart d'avoir eu
il pense que sarkozy a mangé le cerveau
de macron et que donc il est devenu son
nouveau gourou et même sur rtl
quoiqu'il n'ait pas ni l'extrême gauche
ni même spécialement de gauche et ben on
partage cette même thèse oui sarkozy a
mis la main son gouvernement c'est donc
lui qui tire les ficelles dans l'ombre
il faut quand même rappeler les choses
jean castex à matignon darmanin à
l'intérieur bachelot à la culture
dupond-moretti garde des sceaux c'est
vrai que c'est un gouvernement qui
devrait plaire à peu près sur ce j'ai
pas pu le vérifier mais que sarkozy se
réveille de très très bonne humeur ce
matin parce que sa franchise il devait
être content son nom dans tous les
journaux baïlador un son téléphone qui
le départ a été de ce n'est même pas le
temps de répondre c'est lui qui le
premier ministre j'ai pas le temps non
mais ça on se doute que pour lui ça
devait être un vrai qu'il le dit nicolas
sarkozy
sa phrase c'est la politique coule dans
mes veines comme mon sens et donc il
explique que c'est souvent d'ailleurs
pour ça pour cette raison qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à s'arrêter de faire de
la politique parce qu'il est accro vous
savez que c'est quasiment impossible de
s'arrêter quand on est accro 1 pourtant
il devrait s'arrêter de faire de la
politique nicolas sarkozy il le sait
bien lui même que dès qu'il fait de la
politique surtout si c'est pour donner
le sentiment de soutenir macron ça crée
de la confusion et ça pénalise les
républicains il le dit lui même l'an
dernier écoutez le mais aujourd'hui ma
place n'est plus là il n'est plus là
définitivement
parce que dans la vie politique
partisane si je revenais s'amènerait de
la confusion et on n'a vraiment pas
besoin
sauf qu'aujourd'hui on a vraiment
l'impression que la barre était
aujourd'hui on nous dit que c'est lui
qui tire toutes les ficelles dans
l'ombre mais enfin il ya aussi une autre
manière
décrire la situation c'est qu'on
pourrait imaginer que c'est plutôt en
fait macron qui s'est mis sarkozy dans
la poche sur ce coup là ah oui
expliquez-nous ça moi je n'ai rien
inventé un c'est là la théorie de
rachida dati qui dit depuis le début aux
nicolas sarkozy nicolas macron ne t'aime
pas en fait ils te neutralisent et c'est
vrai que sans les signes d'affection ne
le montrent pas de la part de macron à
l'égard de sarkozy il l'invitait
d'emblée à l'elysée avec carla en 2017
en 2018 il a demandé son avis sur les
gilets jaunes il a même rétabli les
heures sup défiscalisées avec ce qu'il a
fait après ben il doit donner des noms
une émission au nom de la france en
géorgie au japon il l'invitait dans les
grandes cérémonies qui compte plateau
des glières il invitait cérémonies du
débarquement en provence brieuc et
pourquoi il fait ça pourquoi tant
d'égards mais c'est parce que je voulais
dire parce que il veut se le mettre dans
la poche moi je ne vois ça que ça comme
explication vous dire que ce m sarkozy
dans la poche
ça s'appelle de la pop hall de la
politique c'est à dire que c'est quand
même un très joli coup sarkozy sa came
un poids lourd aujourd'hui encore nous
baignons regarder les sondages
quand on demande aux français quelle est
leur homme politique préféré sarkozy est
sur le podium juste derrière hulot et le
pire c'est quand on demande aux gens de
droite alors le gérant de droite sarkozy
fait un carton regarder il est même plus
populaire que baroin est bertrand qui
sont pourtant est censé être les deux
favoris pour se présenter à droite en
2002 donc forcément ce maître sarkozy de
la poche
c'est quand même un atout énorme ça ça
met le bazar chez les républicains
et est-ce qu'il peut compter sur sarkozy
chez pas aux européennes par exemple
nicolas sarkozy a refusé d'appeler pour
les républicains il a dit non je reste
neutre
alors moi il ya un truc que je comprends
bien c'est pourquoi marc qu'on veut se
mettre sarkozy dans la poche
ça c'est pour éclater la droite en 2002
ça paraît évident ce que je comprend pas
en revanche c'est pourquoi sarkozy lui
revient dans le jeu
quitte à pénaliser la droite est à
risque de faire perdre son camp ça je
n'arrive pas pour rebondir sur votre
papier merci stéphane s'il ya bien
quelqu'un qui le connaît sur ce plateau
nicolas sarkozy c'est vous cherche
fennecs
kika fluence qui c'est le grand
marionnettiste deux amis l'autre dans la
poche si ces macro hockey me sarkozy
dans sa poche ou à la mer sarkozy qui
est bon dans sa poche
là où je vous rejoins c'est fait
effectivement les deux hommes
s'entendent bien et moi je trouve dans
une démocratie apaisée c'est pas si
mauvais que ça qu'un président puisse
consulter ou avoir de bons rapports avec
ses assesseurs se trouve qu'il ya des
affinités entre l'un et l'autre
mais de là à penser qu' il y ait d
arrière cassé la droite et ses
gouvernements
comment pas y avoir de coïncidence est
ce que vous y voyez la patte de nicolas
sarkozy jean castex quand même je
comprends maintenant le choix judicieux
qui a été fait puisque c'est celui de
nicolas où les bienvenus là je veux pas
si les relations entre regarder les
sondages avaient déjà des sondages et
73% des français qui trouve ça bon choix
tout ce gouvernement même dupond-moretti
ya plus d'opinions favorables que
défavorable 43 pour 37 non contre ben
non c'est la présidentielle y aura trois
blocs un bloc de droite modérée un blog
d'extrême droite et un bloc de gauche la
gauche pas s'éparpiller tout seul comme
d'hab le fn va rester stable
et si à droite c'est le summum seule
marge de manoeuvre le fait de donner le
sentiment aux électeurs de droite qu'on
est soutenu par sarkozy qu'on a gouverné
avec son assentiment
c'est quand même un point fort pour le
centenaire du 1 au delà de ça au-delà de
ça y est il est vrai que ce que ce
gouvernement la politique qui est menée
d'ailleurs sur un plan plus général on
sera peut-être pas d'accord chers
collègues mais c'est quand même une
politique plus de droite que de gauche
assure plan économique et tout donc il y
a là un recrutement de gens qui étaient
calmes estampillé républicains comme
bachelot comme roselyne bachelot comme
jean castex d'ailleurs le premier
ministre et ceux qui ont été gardés
darmanin bruno le maire et c' est qu' il
y a effectivement de mon point de vue
une volonté sans doute de dévitaliser la
droite à la proche de 2022 la gauche
n'en parlons pas à l'état qu'est ce que
je vois non mais vous avez vous avez
raison il ya certainement ce cabinet
d'instruments nicolas sarkozy je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse y est
l'instrument ce qui reste une autorité
de tutelle chine
quelques uns des ventes chez le tour le
dit lui-même mais il continue à inspirer
d'autres familles politiques puis
attendez va y avoir une émergence qui
avaient cru en macro il ya un an avant
l'élection présidentielle 2017 laisser
le temps au temps et vous verrez que
sans doute à droite comme à gauche
d'ailleurs je pense aussi qu'à gauche il
y aura une personnalité qui va émerger
l'argent et qu'on avance et qu'on parle
d' eric dupond moretti
parce que voilà georges fenech s'est
exprimé sur nicolas sarkozy mais l'homme
qui nous intéresse ce soir c'est cet
avocat tonitruant premier discours
premier élément pour peut-être capter le
style et puis surtout ses relations avec
les magistrats
on écoute le nouveau garde des sceaux
c'était ce matin placement dont je le
fais de guerre à personne je veux avec
vous garder le meilleur échange est le
pire
je vous ai adressé un messages
bienveillants à toute la famille
judiciaire magistrats greffiers membres
des professions réglementées dont je
recevrai tous les représentants
je serai le garde des sceaux du dialogue
et j'accepterai la contradiction dont
est toujours été le cerveau défenseur
didier parisse est ce que ce discours
peut suffire à rassurer les magistrats
après tout ce qu'il a déversé de
violence sur la magistrature je reprends
caste endogame barbe aux république des
juges j'en ai rencontré des juges
toute ma vie mais des bons juges pas
beaucoup comment on peut faire pour à
réparer le gouvernement de castex c'est
un gouvernement d'action et donc on
jugera le ministre dupont moretti sur
son action un discours en lui-même est
important parce qu'il fixe un cadre
j'étais ce matin place vendôme
j'étais extrêmement attentif à ce qu'il
disait fixe un cadre il est évident
qu'un discours ne suffira pas à
restaurer une forme de confiance entre
lui et les corps judiciaire qui sont des
filiales de la magistrature inquiète le
syndicat majoritaire bruyère ces
violentes vous les comprenez vous le
magistrat ce que je comprends c'est que
les magiciens
attendent du ministre une protection une
évolution un positionnement une espèce
de de pondération dont encore judiciaire
a besoin les avocats eux aussi les
avocats il sort d'une crise première
crise la grève massive contre la
retraite bien ou mal
on en juge pas mais g massive contre la
retraite suivi de la crise qu'ovide la
profession d'avocat dont vous savez
comme moi que un tiers à peu près
d'entre eux sont vraiment à des niveaux
de rémunérations extrêmement faible elle
a besoin d'être rassurée elle aussi est
ce que opération est ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'il incarne pas du tout
la pondération vous l'avez regardé vous
avez montré tout à l'heure c'est assez
frappant un discours 2018 c'est pas
c'est pas très loin ou 1018 il disait
moi jamais ministre jacobs le demandera
sinon ce serait le bordel tu te fais
chier ce serait bordel c'est gucci c'est
lui qui prenait ça prouve qu'il est en
capacité d'évoluer moi je fais confiance
ans qui est né à mâcon son choix les
jean castex son choix non mais on va
rester sur les strings son choix c'est à
dire que je crois que c'est pas une
bombe à retardement
on est dans un rôle particulier je ne
crois pas une seconde qu'ils ne fassent
pas une mutation rapide
il ne sert à rien de kalley faisant
croyait qu'il restera ministre de la
justice et à la fin de quatre mois j'ai
eu un échange avec lui et quelques-uns
de mes collègues parlementaires ce matin
j'ai vu quelqu'un que je connaissais pas
personnellement
en dehors de la presse un des lecteurs
de la presse qui est intelligent qui a
manifestement au sens des réalités
je pense qu'il aura un sens de la
réalité mais en même temps il est donc
son rôle de vouloir faire avancer à ses
rangs de chance la ville pour cerner le
personnage à part pourquoi ils détestent
autant les juges il aime le
contradictoire
il l'a dit d'ailleurs et ça c'est vrai
mandy alors on va rester dans le
vocabulaire pendant l'été mot-à-mot agit
d suis désolé mais un jour je lui ai dit
mais pourquoi vous détester autant les
magistrats m'a dit je déteste pas les
magistrats je déteste les cons voilà
c'était synonyme de non pas forcément
vrai qu' il le dit hein
je n'ai pas rencontré beaucoup de grands
juges dit il voilà alors le problème
après moi je ne fais pas de politique
matin comme à ce matin mais c'est une
archive précédente
oui au contraire même c'est une vie qui
l'évolution est certainement mais
raciste congénitale d'avocats celui qui
a obtenu de plus d'acquittement au fond
en en plaidant devant le jury citoyen le
juré d'assises contre les juges
comment on explique cette divorcée puis
cette violence surtout alors je pense
moi je fais pas de politique je suis
chroniqueur judiciaire donc mon terrain
de jeu c'est le prétoire
donc il est évident qu eric dupond
moretti est un grand avocat
voilà maintenant est ce qu'il sera un
grand gars de dessau ça je peux pas vous
le dire
ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est un
personnage clivant très clivant et dans
une société qui est déjà fracturé on
peut se poser la question de savoir quel
aimez vous le dites vous même
là on parle que d'eric dupond moretti
dans la constitution de ce gouvernement
c'est le d'ailleurs pourrais m'en
réjouir c'est la première fois qu'on
parle autant de la nomination d'un garde
des sceaux qui pourtant est rétrogradé
de la 4e à la che vicieux me 10e place
donc c'est un coup c'est juste un coup
politique pour vous un coup de com g je
ne sais rien je moi je fais pas de
politique mais j'en ai peur en fait le
juste la justice et pas de la télé
réalité c'est des gens qui sont jugés
tous les jours c'est des tribunaux qui
sont dans un état lamentable qui manque
de moyens des prisons qui sont dans un
état aussi dramatique
on va parler de cette feuille de route
mais c'est une personnalité vous le
connaissez bien alors expliquez nous
pourquoi il a changé d'avis vous avez dû
en parler avec avec lui de 2,7
chancellerie début je m'étais moi de
vous dire à quel point j'ai été
choquée gêner la réaction du syndicat de
principal la magistrature csm qui est
d'habitude modéré et qui d'entrée de jeu
comme ça se permet de dire c'est un
personnage controversé
c'est une provocation c'est une
déclaration de guerre
je crois pas qu'en employant ces termes
là un garde des sceaux qui vient d'être
nommé ça redore l'image de la justice
et peut-être contre ça justement qui se
bat voyez-vous contre une magistrature
il faut pas tout mettre dans le même
panier tension il le dit bien d'après ce
que vous avez dit il se bat contre ce
qui outre passe et qu'on des magistrats
qui ne se contente plus d'appliquer la
loi mais de faire par exemple des
dépositions d'avoir des positions
politiques ou bien de faire de la morale
c'est ce qu'il dit aussi il dit ses
jumeaux moi je suis mais vraiment
enthousiaste jours quelle raison parce
que c'est vraiment quelqu'un épris de
justice
on le voit c'est charnel ces mots qui
l'employait d'ailleurs aujourd'hui à
vous y étiez chers collègues il l'a donc
année les prétoires intimement
charnellement et il va mettre un grand
coup de pied je dirais dans une
magistrature que j'aime à laquelle j'ai
appartenu et mais qui restait un peu
sclérosé et un peu repliés sur eux mêmes
par un phénomène de corporatisme des
comptes touche quelque chose c'est tout
de suite le branle bas de combat
je sais qu'il va avoir énormément
difficultés pour faire passer ses idées
dont une des principales d'ailleurs qui
va sans doute faire une levée de
boucliers c'est enfin de clarifier le ce
qu'est le partant là et venir et ce
qu'est le siège parce que ce qu'a
toujours défendu en fait eric c'est
dupont moretti c'est que il ya un
déséquilibre dans le procès pénal
on va y venir tout de suite mais je
voudrais quand même vous faire entendre
vos collègues de la représentation
nationale ce choix d'eric dupond-moretti
coup de génie ou coup de folie
écoutez c'est d'abord un pari médiatique
ça au sud une personnalité haute en
couleurs moi j'apprécie un certain
nombre de ses positions mais voilà vous
savez c'est une chose d'être connue
d'être reconnue aussi dans sa profession
sa tenue d'une autre ensuite d'exercer
me sert la justice c'est un avocat
sans doute respectable à titre personnel
mais qui a défendu des causes abominable
les affairistes balkany cahuzac des
terroristes le frère meira les voyous et
que donc le maître ministre de la
justice est envoyé un signal détestable
au pays
monsieur dupont moretti sans doute
devrait être du fait de son expérience
personnelle plus sensibles aux droits de
la défense que madame bérubé qui n'en
savez rien n'y connaissez rien et puis
une réussite et des cours de première
année de droit
à chaque fois qu'on lui pose une
question ici au parlement
sans parler des femmes ou quand même
dupond-moretti vraiment eu des paroles
horribles et de surcroît était hostile
par exemple au délit d outrage sexistes
donc que c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour les honnêtes gens et pour les
femmes
voilà un homme de conviction personne
comme lui enlever ça et dans ses
convictions c'est la suppression du
parquet financier c'est la séparation du
parquet et du siège
c'est la suppression de l'école
nationale de la magistrature donc la
question qu'il faut poser maintenant c
est ce que c'est pour ça que vous êtes
venu à la place vendôme alors réponse
didier paris c'est vrai que c'est assez
lunaire la situation dans laquelle il se
retrouve aujourd'hui il faut rappeler
qu'il a il a laissé tomber sa plainte il
a retiré sa plainte plainte contre
justement le parquet le pnf le parc
national financiers dans la sphère dit
des écoutes téléphoniques liées aux
fadettes qui ont été décidées par le pnf
d'eliane houlette on a parlé ici même à
l'assemblée et qui ont abouti à des géo
localisation de téléphone à des factures
détaillées donc s'est procuré le parquet
les notamment de celle de d'eric
dupond-moretti et de nombreuses autres
avocats
aujourd'hui c'est lui qui va recevoir
l'inspection générale de la justice on
rapporte ça semble presque ubuesque
totalement impossible cette situation là
c'est pas une situation facile je
présume que au moment où il a fait son
choix et au moment le désigne ces
éléments ont été pris en compte parce
que je remarque si on permettait c'est
que la justice c'est la justice du
quotidien c'est pas que la justice du
parc kent dossier
financée pour répondre attendez la
gageure si c'est aussi la justice'' ving
sociales commerciales ainsi de suite et
il faudra bien que le ministre une
vision large
ensuite le pnf on peut accuser parquet
de tous les maux surtout quand ils vous
concerne quand j'entends jean luc
mélenchon je suis un peu atterré quand
même de ce qu'il dit mais en réel
il nous faut bien à un bras séculier de
l'état pour aller poursuivre les
infractions graves qui sont de l'ordre
du parquet national financiers donc
après effectivement dès lors une
situation parce mairie a mis 4 il faudra
qu'ils se déporte qu'il faudra qu'ils
aient beaucoup de moi je pense que 2000
il ya déjà des soupçons de conflits
d'intérêt quand on regarde mon boulot
c'est dans les semaines qui se pose
c'est la petite lorgnette tout ça je
vais vous dire il a retiré sa plainte
le conseil de l'ordre a suspendu leurs
plates moi je serais à la place d'eric
dupond-moretti
je demanderai à l'inspection des scellés
judiciaires d'arrêter cette inspection
point barre il faut arrêter mais bien
sur les fadettes dans la ferme
elles sont indépendantes écoutait ses
fadettes elles sont dans la légalité
alors après est-ce que c'était important
de le faire
on peut se poser la question mais il est
évident que le parquet se réfugie avec
avait le pouvoir de faire cela il faut
arrêter c'est secondaire
belle et rincon vie je me tourner vers
ma consoeur parquet général
c'est secondaire cette affaire qu'on
plonge en valeur c'est pas c'est pas
secondaire et d'abord cette affaire elle
était connue des gens qui fréquentent
les palais de justice quand même depuis
assez longtemps donc c'est pas nouveau
c'est scandaleux pour la défense donc ça
m'étonnerait que eric dupond moretti
dans son interview d'ailleurs il a il
l'a très bien dit apprécient ce genre de
comportement maintenant je pense pas je
pense qu'il ne peut pas il ne peut pas
arrêter a arrêté ces inspections et de
toute façon il s'en servira même
certainement pour séparer le alors on y
va
le siège et le parquet ce qu'il veut
faire parce que c'est étonnant quand on
regarde le programme d' emmanuel macron
programme de campagne présidentielle n'y
a pas cette réforme du parquet et
pourtant écouter à nouveau
eric dupond-moretti ce matin j'entends
bien sûr dans le dialogue et la
concertation faire évoluer la
magistrature dans le change d'une plus
grande ouverture sur la société et
remettre à plat l'ordonance de 58
je veux avancer sur un projet qui me
tient à coeur
l'indépendance de la justice je souhaite
être le garde des sceaux qui portera
enfin lors d'un congrès la réforme du
parquet tant attendu transfennec cette
réforme du parquet précisé mme nous un
peu les choses parce que ça fait des
années et des années qu'on en pense aux
jeunes étaient co rapporteurs précédents
mandats donc je connais le texte ça va
pas changer grand chose en fait
qu'est-ce qui a dans cette réforme qui
prévoit une révision constitutionnelle
qu'il exige une réforme passionnel
c'est finalement conforter la pratique
c'est à dire que pour qu'un procureur
soit nommé il faut à l'heure actuelle on
peut passer outre à l'avis négatif du
conseil des ministres à tursac et pose
problème c'est à dire que c'est en vrai
c'est le sait la chancellerie dans le
registre de la justice en location
finale sur les nominations dans le
projet de la réforme constitutionnelle
il est prévu que l'exécutif toujours
propose du nomination mais ne peut pas
nommer sans l'avis favorable donc c'est
comme pour les magistrats du siège en
aligne finalement moi je pense que c'est
une réformette je veux pourquoi parce
que c'est dans la pratique déjà depuis
dix ans et qui a plus un seul garde des
sceaux qui est la vraie réforme
et c'est d'ailleurs que réclament les
énergies ce thème en est la voie la
séparation marqué ce serait de faire
que c'est le csm qui propose les noms
des procureurs comme pour les magistrats
du siège
et là vous déconnecter et vous enlevez
la suspicion sur le parquet parce qu'il
veut non si vous êtes nommé par
quelqu'un vous sentez quelque part un
peu là dessus sur les nominés ça ne fait
pas trop d'illusions ça va passer la
nomination des procureurs disent ce qui
est clair c'est que on a besoin d'une
réforme il n'y a aucun doute
je suis rapporteur de la commission d'
enquête sur des pans de la justice au
cours de laquelle madame boulet tu as
fait un centre de déclarations qui ont
déclenché une émission j'ai l'impression
d'une absence de consensus
sir fait qu'il faut faire que le parquet
à la française notre note de parquet de
vienne un parquet indépendant
vianne csm je suis d'accord avec mon
collègue ça change pas fou ce
foncièrement les choses mais ça ça donne
l'aspect symbolique dont nous avons
besoin d'eux mais vous savez comme moi
que on s'est heurté un problème de
réformes constitutionnelles plus large
parce que le csm c'est la réforme du
parquet
c'est la suppression de la cour de
justice de la république en fait ces
éléments là peuvent faire consensus il
faut que nous soyons en capacité de
reprendre et j'ai cru comprendre que le
ministre souhaitait le faire on va
s'étendre à gozée parce que d'après sera
rentable par deux grilles de jeu vous
car je veux dire je nous fais mine est
certain qu'il est pas aussi dans la tête
réparation alors écouté et je leur donne
la parole tout de suite après c'était
chez nos confrères de lci
david pujadas lui demandait c'était il
ya quelques jours
et si vous étiez mini de la justice que
feriez vous d'abord il faut qu'on sépare
le siège du parquet vous avez les
procureurs d'un côté qui poursuivent et
vous avez les juges qui sont censé juger
et dans une justice mieux penser il
faudrait qu'il y ait le juge chargé de
juger le procureur l'avocat une
équidistance entre tout cela dans une
triangulation très clair ça n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui ils sont cousins
germains
ils ont fait la même école on passe
d'ailleurs de l'un à l'autre ont
peut-être procureurs juges du siège du
siège procureur on saute de branche en
branche tout ça ne gêne personne
donc d'abord moi je fais le ménage
là-dedans
façon très très très clair voilà c'est
une réforme de la justice bien plus
ambitieuse que celle dont vous parlez il
a un instant ce dont ils parlent
soyez pédagogique pour ceux qui nous
regardent est ce que ça ne pourrait plus
être magistrat du siège qui ont choisi
le parquet qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
magistrat du siège
le magistrat du siège c'est celui qui
juge à celui qui a condamné un
patriarcat nice et celui qui a condamné
ce soir à la cheville et au milieu et
que je suis à côté il sur le siège à
l'exil à l'année ensuite vous avez le
magistrat du parquet qui est là pour
représenter l'état la force publique
c'est poursuivre c'est poursuivre la
société n'en a pas les tabacs l'état à
l'état je retire j'en retire ce que j'ai
dit mais justement voyez le lapsus est
intéressant parce que le soupçon il se
porte pas sur le juge du siège celui
qu'ils jugent ils se portent sur le
parquet et le parquet c'est lui encore
qui accuse celui qui accuse c'est lui
aussi qui va poursuivre et c'est bien
pour ça que il ya eu cette polémique sur
fion et il faut absolument et ça c'est
jean la réforme impossible il faut il
faut séparer ses formes en paix la
branche entre les deux vont trouver un
moyen qu'il n'y ait plus de soupçons
voilà alors j'ai extrêmement exemple
quand on a été par exemple parquetier
antiterroriste et qu'on a poursuivi
est-ce qu'on pourrait se retrouver juge
antiterroriste est ce que c'est pas
impossible de faire les deux jorge
garcia vous permet de stocker nos trente
secondes les parquetiers et les juges du
siège sont issus la raison de la même
école souvent d'ailleurs à l'école on
trouve son conjoint
c'est vrai que c'est l'une des
professions les plus haut de gamme et à
l'école nationale de la magistrature
aborde donc vous avez quoi vous avez un
statut qui prévoit l'unicité du corps
c'est à dire qu'on peut être moi j'étais
procureur je suis devenu juge
d'instruction scheer devenu procureur et
on change et ainsi tu dis ça c'est une
très mauvaise chose
on est les seuls à faire ça il n'y a pas
d'autres démocraties où la bad partout
dans les pays anglo saxons vous avez le
parquet qui est d'abord à la même
hauteur que la défense est tout en haut
vous avez votre honneur le juge
parce qu'il est au dessus des risques en
france vous avez le procureur qui
sortent par la même pièce qui rentrent
même robe
son collègue ils ont fait l'école
ensemble ils sont assis à la même
hauteur et l'avocat est en bas donc il
ya un déséquilibre c'est ça que vous
expliquez régula déséquilibre mais bien
sûr que si elles s'équilibrent en laye
l'accusation et la défense
il faut couper alors non la première je
termine ainsi la donation d'outreau a
prévu à l'époque vous choisissez la
sortie de l'école le parquet au siège
est au bout de cinq ans vous faites un
choix définitif sur vous restez au
parquet soit passé au siège mais il n'y
a plus d' aller retour et au moins les
choses sont claires je pense que c'est
vers ça qui faute alors je lui disais
parfois personnellement que c'est quand
même faire injure au magistrat procureur
au juge du siège sont des magistrats
dans une logique n'est pas du tout la
main ds dans une logique il
oui mais comment georges fenech est
hélas le dit lui-même j'ai fait de l'un
et l'autre est ce que pour autant vous
en ville et poursuivraient autant que
j'aurais été moins indépendants dans une
fonction plutôt que dans une autre
je ne crois pas s'accompagner garde des
sceaux ces ménages l'argus que je
voulais majorité sur ce quator donnez
moi vous le suivez ou pas je réglais
repart demain je l'ait pas entendu dire
que c'était son projet abbas et ce qui
est dit sur lci il ya très clairement
des îles à part les projets tant que
ministre mais il apparaît soyons précis
quand même en tant que ministre il a
parlé dans l'indépendance du parquet
c'est une autre notion moi ce que je
sens poindre derrière et mon collègue
fait référence aux pays anglo saxons
c'est que la séparation des corps mais
pourquoi pas mais c'est une vraie
réflexion de fond ça ouvre quoi ça ouvre
son ordinateur et bliss itancia
l'arrière et nous aurions un système où
finalement vous avez d'un côté le
parquet le procureur du roi au canada où
vous prenez tous les modèles que vous
voulez d'un autre côté la défense à
armes égales et vous et vous avez un
juge qui reste extérieur et qui jugent
la qualité également et c'est un c'est
un schéma juridique culturel louis
social tout à fait différent de celui
qu'on connaît c'est ce qu'a vécu
l'italie il ya quelques années au
deuxième rang l'alcool a fière allure
de nos jours cela puisse vous permettez
ses débats internes à bla il ya
peut-être quelque chose qui vous a
échappé
si vous y étiez purement sûrement
beaucoup est ce qu'il n'a pas dit je
vais mettre à plat l'ordonance de 1958
monsieur c'est sale elle vient portrait
il a dit la leader dehors je suis un
attaquant c'est le statut de la
magistrature c'est l'unission un témoin
parle le vrai que le vrai problème ce
problème de la séparation du siège et du
parquet c'est récurrent depuis journal
je suis jean est judiciaire c'est le
marronnier en ressort faveur mais oui
mais c'est pas ça le problème regardez
les affaires vrai problème c'est c'est
les instructions l'instruction il ya des
leçons internationaux interdits la malle
désastre depuis ces 50 audition par
molson pas une
vous m'entendez a été en capacité mais
on est bien à des instructions on est
bien d'accord ça n'existe pas finalement
on est bien d'accord mais je les risées
avions lardeux pourquoi madame houlette
quand elle dit qu'elle est a eu des
pressions ça fait ça n'a rien à voir
certaines de strictement rien à voir
madame houlette il explique très
précisément que j'ai réentendu madame
champrenault procureur général de paris
nous avons une situation qui est très
clair c'est à dire que le pouvoir
hiérarchique du procureur général de la
cour d'appel de paris sur procurant un
ancien financier est juridiquement
établi il ya aucun doute là dessus
par contre pour des raisons qui seraient
trop longues à expliquer mal madame
houlette à mal ressenti cette pression
il ya nous lâche antique l'ancien logis
panneaux sont une trente secondes peaux
pleinement pour qu'on comprenne bien mon
propos je dis pas qu'il ya des
intrusions jeudi que le saucisson ce que
vous disiez rebond jeudi le problème
c'est les instructions qu'il est le
soupçon d'instruction qu'on a que
problème c'est cela dépasse pas celle
extraits d'autres choses qu'il faut
couper le cordon ombilical une
dépression grenat faux elle n'a pas fait
tout de suite mal exprimé y compris les
avocats y compris les avocats de
monsieur fillon demandé l'ouverture
d'une information judiciaire
au contraire elle a résisté ces publics
chenal je ne trahis rien elle a résisté
une émission l'attend dès la seconde
indépendance
c'est bien c'est cohérent s'est dit
j'aurais qu'on s'intéresse à nos voisins
européens à ce qu il yad autres eric
dupond moretti dans les gouvernements de
nos de nos voisins c'est richard vernis
dans sa chronique qui nous parle de ses
avocats en politique c'est monnaie
courante
le mariage n'est pas toujours idéal il y
à un précédent myriam à un avocat en
politique au sein du pouvoir exécutif
alors on pense bien sûr au cas français
de robert badinter qui fut ministre de
la justice sous françois mitterrand et
parvint à l'abolition de la peine de
mort mais il y en a un autre un nom
important aux etats-unis c'est celui de
robert kennedy qui fut ministre de la
justice sous la présidence de son frère
il était avocat il se lança ensuite dans
la campagne présidentielle de 1968
mais il finit assassiné le 6 juin 1968
deux mois après le meurtre de martin
luther king alors traditionnellement les
avocats en europe pour les retrouve
plutôt du côté du parlement
c'est le cas au bundestag où aujourd'hui
une centaine de députés allemands sur
700 sont des hommes de loi
c'est le cas aussi au royaume uni ou au
xviie siècle 90% des élus étaient des
magistrats ou des avocats des bars
easter comme on dit de l'autre côté de
la manche
aujourd'hui ils ne forment plus que 15%
de la chambre des communes
mais à vrai dire lorsqu il y a eu
polémique sur le rôle politique des
hommes de loi c'est surtout lorsque les
juges décident d'entrer au sein d'un
gouvernement
on l'a vu en italie avec le juge antonio
di pietro le monsieur anti corruption
des années 90 qui avait poursuivi
notamment le président du conseil
socialiste italien bettino craxi et
silvio berlusconi il fut ministre dans
le gouvernement de romano prodi
mais très vite ils se retrouvent à
isoler attaquer
finalisé et il n'a pas su créer de
mouvement populaire autour de lui un
autre exemple en espagne avec baltasar
garzon
c'est le juge qui mena les poursuites
contre le dictateur chilien augusto
pinochet
il s'en était pris à vent aux
terroristes et aussi au crime organisé
et bien même chose il participa au
gouvernement sous felipe gonzalez et il
n'a pas réussi à entrer berry entraîner
derrière lui une fraction de l'opinion
on voit bien la difficulté entré en
politique pour un homme de loi
ça veut dire affronter un véritable défi
parvenir à incarner la justice et l'état
de droit est en quelque sorte rester au
dessus de la politique
merci beaucoup richard georges fenech on
voit que le pari n'est pas forcément
gagné quand on est homme de loi sommes
deux hommes de justice et qu'on bascule
en politique du gouvernement
on a connu de très très grands barrages
en tout cas un grand magistrat vraiment
immérité notre respect qui était un
piètre garde des sceaux faut le dire
sans penser qu'il ya un changement à son
âme
autre question combien de temps eric
dupond-moretti va rester selon vous en
poste au ministère de la justice
le plan rouge 21 plus longtemps logique
nous devrions combien de temps
franchement vous ne disiez en chattant
la première confrontation darmanin
dupond-moretti franchement avec un grand
plaisir la seiche et je prends mon
ministère de l'intérieur est miné le
garde des sceaux
parce que les deux ont une conception
très fortes de leur ministère et ça va
de toute façon historiquement
l'intérieur et la justice ça clash
alors soit on se couche entre guillemets
et on mais c'est le cas de dean ni l'un
ni l'autre ne pas se coucher il a déjà
dit eric dupond moretti qu'il allait en
finir avec les enquêtes préliminaires
interminables auxquels d'oenologie enfin
oui on a vu tout noter enfin dans la
sphère faire trisomique elle a duré
plusieurs années
tout tout tout pour dire c'est que voilà
il n'y a pas de police justice avec un
quart des sauts comme lui ça peut
marcher avec deux hommes forts 1 avec
darmana notamment vous avez raison ça
clashe toujours mais c'est toujours été
comme ça et toujours parce que la
sécurité et puis à la liberté
toujours le même débat dupond-moretti
lâchera rien sur les libertés moi j'en
suis sûr
darmanin lâchera rien sur la sécurité
alors ça promet je marche je commence à
relativement bien connaître et orale
darmanin c'est un homme d'état
je connais pas eric eric dupond-moretti
mais je vais rapidement à mon poste
quelque chose me rencontrer je suis
persuadé qu'il aura lui aussi la la
cense comportement d'un homme d'état à
partir de là les chemises peut être
aussi de chose s'appelle les mêmes
malheurs de l'intérêt public primera sur
tout autre intérêt secondaire intérêt
public intérêts de la justice
on peut lire déjà dans certaines dans
certains commentaires dans certains
analystes qui pourrait être aussi un
rempart contre le rassemblement national
avec cette personnalité qui lui voulait
sans doute les causes les gilet jaune
il a sans doute été choisi il faut le
reconnaître aussi pour son côté
perception du public les sondages
l'attestent bonne perception
les gens peuvent assez facilement se
reconnaître dans une perspective c'est
un peu aussi il faut le reconnaître mais
moi je lui fais pleine confiance sur le
fait qu' on s'arrêtera pas à cette
vision éphémère des choses et qui aura
une vraie construction il l'a dit il
aura les parlementaires à ses côtés pour
faire évoluer une justice qui c'est vrai
est en souffrance des magistrats leur
avait ri terreur les personnels de
justice sont en souffrance on dépit des
énormes efforts qui ont été réalisés par
nicole belloubet y compris la loi de
mars 2019
elle a fait un remarquable travail mais
c'est un travail de longue haleine
travail de longue haleine la justice a
besoin de moyens d'ailleurs ils étaient
ce soir à fresnes premier déplacement
aux côtés des personnels pénitentiaires
y avait pas de questions au gouvernement
aujourd'hui par zones ce nouveau
gouvernement a tenu son premier conseil
des ministres qu'à cela ne tienne
thomas des prêts les en quelque sorte
remplacé n'est ce pas thomas où
exactement myriam d'habitude le mardi
après midi à 15h cette salle des quatre
colonnes est plein à craquer remplie de
journalistes de député cet après-midi
personnes mais pourquoi je vous raconte
tout ça
en fait si les ministres n'étaient pas
présents cet après midi à l'assemblée
pour la traditionnelle séance de
questions hebdomadaires au gouvernement
c'est tout simplement parce qu'ils
étaient à l'elysée autour du président
de la république pour le premier conseil
des ministres du gouvernement castex 1
les ministres étaient tout sourire
autour de la table de ce premier conseil
des ministres mais ici certains députés
de l'opposition à l'assemblée y ont vu
un mauvais signal moi je regrette que le
parlement se sont un peu la dernière
case que l'on coche quand on a rempli
notre agenda
je crois qu'on continue dans le la des
considérations
du parlement déjà on va attendre une
semaine avant qu'ils nous disent qu'ils
veulent faire parce que c'est bien
gentil de faire un casting faut d abord
nous dire quel est le scénario qu elle
est menue qu'est ce qu'ils comptent
faire et tout ça on n'en sait rien et on
va faire ça demain matin c'est un peu
cavalier de la part du lancement
nous on a demandé au président du groupe
majoritaire la république en marche est
ce que les députés de l'opposition ont
raison de se sortir bafoués est ce que
ce n'est pas un peu surjouée de
reprendre au brh parce que les questions
au gouvernement sont déplacés d'un mardi
15h un mercredi 11h je suis sûr que les
français ont envie de participer à cette
polémique absolument essentiel pour leur
vie quotidienne
alors si le nouveau gouvernement avaient
été présents dans l'hémicycle cet après
midi il aurait répondu dans ce micro à
la trentaine de questions que leur
aurait posé les députés mais d'ailleurs
que souhaiter leur demander les députés
pour cette première séance de questions
au gouvernement
avec dominique fauvel et rabih cas ce
matin on est allé leur poser la question
aussi les questions au gouvernement
avait eu aujourd'hui quelles questions
vous auriez aimé poser au nouveau
gouvernement
un peu du tac au tac pour réagir au
symbole qu'a voulu donner à sa visite
dans un commissariat du 93 de nouveau
premier ministre
j'aurais peut-être je lui aurais
peut-être demander quelles mesures il
compte prendre face à l'évidence des
violences policières mais aussi des
exactions commises par certaines
brigades sur ces sujets moi j'aurais
volontiers demander quelle est la
mission de d'eric dupond-moretti
est ce que c'est il est là pour mettre
en place les convictions qui sont les
siennes et que je peux comprendre la
suppression de l'école de la
magistrature la séparation du parquet
les juges du par
du siège c'est ça les trois émissions il
ya un grand chantier de réforme de la
justice qui est en cours on a droit de
savoir
une question à retenir c'est madame
pompili qu'est ce que vous faites dans
un gouvernement où monsieur le maire
monsieur darmanin et d'autres élus sont
pro nucléaires et est favorable à la
relance économique alors que vous vous
êtes contre le nucléaire et pour la
décroissance durable alors pour suivre
les réponses de ce nouveau gouvernement
rendez-vous demain matin en direct des
11heures sur lcp pour les questions au
gouvernement
et nous on se retrouvera demain pour une
nouvelle journée à l'assemblée georges
fenech au fond est ce que c'est parce à
ce qu'on attende d'eric dupond-moretti
le spectacle ces questions au
gouvernement imaginez jean luc mélenchon
qui pose une question nouveau garde des
sceaux qui lui même était l'avocat des
policiers dans le procès qu'il qui l'a
opposé la sur la perquisition ce qui fut
de son siège tellement de mal nos
institutions c'est le spectacle quand
vous avez installé vous les attendez
césar au ladakh le politique
ça n'est pas au bénéfice de nos
institutions moi j'attends vraiment
qu'elle vous croyez pas qu'il ait choisi
aussi un peu plus je pense qu'il a une
personnalité et je pense qu'il sera là
tenir son rang de garde des sceaux en or
- alain si deux ou trois mois un tiers
non je suis désolé que vous caricature y
ait à ce point vraiment une incidence
inquiète c'est une question que tout le
monde se pose on parle de la
personnalité de m
pour lui la nation les mici que c'est
pas c'est pas les plateaux de télévision
les mystères de justice non plus il est
dans un rôle aujourd'hui il va l'assumé
complètement j'en suis absolument
convaincu le dis on vérifiera tout cela
va dans les jours et les 18 mois qui
nous restent avant l'échéance
présidentielle merci infiniment d'avoir
participé à ce débat
on va maintenant parler de la 5g la
nouvelle génération de téléphonie mobile
suscite une véritable levée de boucliers
depuis les municipales et même bien
avant avant la vague verte
les opposants semblent de plus en plus
nombreux les actions sabotage des
antennes se multiplient alors est-ce que
la 5g
c'est un problème la mise au point d'un
mètre à dire avant d'accueillir nos
invités après la 4g est bienvenu à la 5g
la cinquième génération de téléphonie
mobile
déjà présent dans une vingtaine de pays
dont les etats-unis la corée du sud la
chine suisse elle devrait arriver en
france avant la fin de l'année mais au
fait qu'est-ce que les cinq juges va
apporter
alors vous allez avoir une vitesse de
connexion internet sur votre smartphone
qui va être dix fois plus rapide que la
4g mais aussi quand vous allez envoyer
et recevoir des informations
il va y avoir dix fois moins de latence
et enfin pour les utilisateurs en fait
quand vous allez vous connectez vous
allez très nombreux dans un lieu comme
un stade de foot ou un concert vous
allez avoir beaucoup moins deux
phénomènes de congestion du réseau
parce que le réseau va avoir dix fois
plus de capacité être opérateurs se sont
positionnés en france orange sfr
bouygues et free
il y à des opérateurs et il ya ceux qui
les équipent le champion mondial c'est
le chinois huawei devant les européens à
nokia ericsson mais là il y a un
problème il est soupçonné uniquement
parce qu'ils les chinois en fait
huawei est fourni du matériel aux
opérateurs depuis plusieurs décennies en
france on n'a jamais constaté problème
mais par principe et dans le doute
dans le cas où un jour il pour le
gouvernement chinois pourrait utiliser
huawei pour espionner de communication
ou même les interrompre la france a
préféré prendre un décret et elle impose
maintenant aux opérateurs de demander
une autorisation avant d'installer une
antenne est bien entendu évidemment une
antenne huawei alors on sait comment ça
va se profiler il ya certaines enseignes
qui vont être interdites sur le
territoire dans des lieux qui sont
plutôt sensible et pour les autres
antennes huawei ça va être une durée
limitée qui va pas être imposée à nokia
ericsson
outre le souci de la souveraineté
numérique la 5g fait face à des levées
de boucliers notamment pour l'impact
potentiel sur la santé et
l'environnement c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
numérique consomme 4 % de l'aimer 4 %
des gaz à effet de serre il est prévu
que sa double d'ici cinq ans pour que
vous puissiez savoir combien vous avez
de yaourt dans votre frigidaire que
vraiment est ce que le progrès c'est de
pouvoir regarder des films pornos en hd
grosso modo la 5g et pour nous permettre
de regarder des films pornos même quand
vous êtes dans votre ascenseur en hd
aujourd'hui aucune étude scientifique
n'a prouvé que les ondes
électromagnétiques sont dangereuses
à condition de respecter les limites de
puissance recommandé par l'organisation
mondiale de la santé est imposé par les
états bonsoir emile meunier soir vous
êtes nouveau conseiller de paris europe
ecologie les verts vous venez d'être élu
aux dernières municipales dans la
capitale bienvenue à vous françois
durpaire tandis que cette émission
parlera un peu plus tard avec vous de la
guerre entre trump et pékin justement au
sujet de la 5g et puis laurent alexandre
et en duplex avec nous bonsoir monsieur
alexandre d'être entrepreneur
cofondateur de doctissimo
on verra avec vous pourquoi vous
plébiscitez cette nouvelle technologie
mais celui qui milite contre la 5g c'est
vous il n'y ni pour quelle raison
précisément à bas de nombreuses raisons
des réseaux sanitaires déjà le principe
de précaution et bouleversements vont
être considérables ça va transformer la
société du tout au tout et avant de
s'engager dans cette voie il serait
quand même bon d'avoir des études un peu
sérieuse justement les études il n'ya
pas d'étude vient de prouver de manière
irréfutable que la 5g mauvaise pour la
santé est en venant là en vélo je me
cherchais un parallèle pour essayer de
faire comprendre aux gens ce que c'était
que la 5g et la 3g vous aviez une
autoroute de voix puis un moment elle a
été saturé parce que vous avez vos
téléphones portables aux ordinateurs des
sites de plus en plus lourd pour
commander un billet de train on se
retrouve avec une masse considérable de
numérique de publicité etc
puis on s'est dit ah ben on va
construire deux voies supplémentaires la
4g et puis quelques années après ad non
je fais le parallèle vous allez
comprendre ce que je veux dire parce que
c'est pas de voix supplémentaires qu'on
ajoute la voûte de voix supplémentaires
ont été remplies et là maintenant on
nous dit on va faire voler des avions au
dessus de l'autoroute
voilà des couloirs d'avion et on va
passer nos pas d'un changement de
2° et d'échelle mais d'un changement de
nature toute la société qui va être
impactée
et quand il résume à g et ça fait peur
ce que vous dites mais vous le fondée
sur quelles données scientifiques parce
que plus on entend votre collègue et 3
nuls
eric piolle à grenoble être un peu
caricatural comme en dix ans la 5g c'est
pour regarder du porno a été emmené à
l'ascenseur c'est au niveau ça
franchement au moins l'image marque et
on a le débat et ça c'était important et
lorsqu'on écoute eric piolle et le
travail formidable qui fait à grenoble
pour ses habitants et ses habitantes
ça mérite qu'on s'y intéresse il a des
belles choses à dire sur le sujet vous à
paris alors alors mon père parce qu'eric
tu l'as dit qu'on l'avait pas mis au
courant pour l'installation des antennes
et le passage à 5 g qu'est ce qui se
passe dans la capitale ce qui se passe
c'est qu'on va installer des antennes
sans consulter les habitants sans qu'on
ait eu le moindre débat au parlement
encore une fois c'est un changement de
nature on va pas multiplier par deux la
vitesse soit la x 10 dans un premier
temps puis par sans la vitesse c'est
tout autre mode de vie qui va te
souhaite tous vos objets là votre
bracelet votre papier toilette pour
caricaturer sera connecté ça va être une
masse considérable d'ondés
électromagnétiques et donc on va rentrer
dans un nouveau monde avant de rentrer
dans ce monde là la moindre des choses
c'est qu'on prenne le temps de s'asseoir
et de faire les études qui comprend bien
vous demander un moratoire moratoire une
demande est évidemment l'arrêt du
passage à la 5g non mais pour l'instant
on arrête tout moratoire on regarde les
études et ont fait le nombre d'études
qu'il faut et pour moi c'est un débat
suffisamment important pour que ce soit
du niveau par exemple une présidentielle
et vous que les français et françaises
puissent se prononcer sur un mode de vie
un mode de société qui va être le leur
laurent alexandre qu'est ce que vous
répondez à emile meunier l'écologiste
qui demande au fond qu'on qu'on discute
collectivement du sujet avant la
présidentielle
c'est cette peur technologique on a
connu la même chose quand le chemin de
fer est arrivé en tant que médecin j'ai
avec amusement regarder ce que les gens
racontaient en 1840 au sujet des
conséquences dramatiques du chemin de
fer alors ça allait tuer les vaches ça
allait faire avorter les femmes on
allait devenir
les ressources on est allé à voir des
grandes maladies notamment dans l'est
dans les tunnels et hilal c'est quand on
allait dépasser 30 km heure alors si on
avait expliqué houle gens de cette
époque là aujourd'hui on irait à 320
kilomètres heure de paris à strasbourg
il aurait été effectivement paniquer
donc les peurs technologiques comme
celle qui exprime notre invité il faut
les respecter
elles ont existé de tout temps mais les
maisons gisent sur la santé monsieur
alexandre vous êtes certains que c'est
inoffensif
écoutez il n'y a aucune étude aucune
étude au monde qui est montré que les
réseaux de communication soient mauvais
pour la santé
et en tant que médecin spécialisé dans
le domaine de la cancérologie urologique
j'ai consacré pas mal de d'années de ma
vie
si j'avais le moindre doute sur un
risque cancérologique de la salle g je
militerai sur le champ pour que on
interdise la 5g
vous imaginez bien que je ne tolérerai
pas une seconde que mes enfants ma
famille les citoyens soient menacés par
cette technologie sont des membres
laurent elle existe en annonces et
pardonnez moi je voudrais pas content
mais je vous relance avec cette question
vous le médecin en quoi la 5g est un
progrès pour pour la médecine pour la
chirurgie de demain alors d'abord on n'a
pas le choix parce que si nous
continuons à décliner technologiquement
et scientifiquement en europe et en
particulier en france
on va devenir une colonie de
technologique nous nous sommes effondrés
en maître haute technologie en europe
nous avons perdu beaucoup de batailles
dans l'univers des télécoms si nous
faisons un moratoire sur la 5g nous
allons perdre énormément en termes de
croissance et qui va payer
ce sont les gens modestes ce sont les
gilets jaunes dont le pouvoir d'achat va
s'effondrer dans les années qui viennent
on sait que ça mérite un qui parle si la
france est particulier monsieur alex en
oublie mais si la france et demain à
pays développés les gilets jaunes on n'a
pas fini de les voir descendre dans la
rue parce que ce ne sont pas les bobos
verts qui vont souffrir si on a un
effondrement de l'économie
ce sont les pauvres gens ce sont les
gens modestes ce sont eux qui ont besoin
que nous ayons une économie haut de
gamme
technologiquement avancée parce que si
on a une technologie bas de gamme
si on perd la guerre technologies
face à l'asie et face aux états unis on
aura un effondrement du niveau de vie
vous me le relais compétitivité vous
parlez alors parlé de la technologie la
médecine pour parler de la médecine
je ne comprends pas qu'on puisse être
contre la 5g ça va permettre de
développer beaucoup d'application de
télémédecine de téléchirurgie ça va
permettre aux médecins de faire des
diagnostics de haute qualité à distance
grâce à la caméra du smartphone il y à
un unis des rentiers en matière de soins
aux personnes âgées de monitoring des
personnes âgées de monitoring des
malades
il ya un univers extraordinaire dans mon
domaine qui est le domaine de la santé
là je ne parle même pas d'économie donc
être contre la 5g aujourd'hui c'est
possible archaïque que d'être contre le
train en 1830 et il y avait beaucoup de
gens comme votre invité en 1830
je respecte ce jour je pense qu'il faut
rassurer les gens qui sont contre la 5g
qui ont peur de la technologie c'est une
phobie comme une autre ça s'appelle la
technophobie mais si la france toute
entière suisse ce discours technophobie
qu une chose est certain nos enfants au
malbouffe et deux enfants ont moins bien
soignés leur niveau de vie va baisser et
la france et l'europe seront demain une
colonie technologique des pays acp et
ses commerces un dialogue et la corée du
sud
vous restez avec nous lors en élection
ou techno phobique vous êtes archaïque
et me meunier à écouter laurent
alexandre qu'est-ce que vous ne
répondrez anti progrès technologiques
alors je peins je ne suis pas
technophobie q2 j'ai l'impression que je
suis alexandre et techno gaga est ce que
s'ils pensent que la technologie va
régler tous les problèmes du monde
c'est le discours que les technophiles
tiennent depuis des siècles et ils nous
ont amenés en partie dans l'impasse et
que la médecine par exemple c'est très
concret al hilal et rationnelle et les
opérations chirurgicales c'est l'arbre
qui cache la forêt moi je suis et
l'ensemble des écologistes
on n'est pas contre la croissance on
écoute la croissance sélective
il ya des belles choses dans la
technologie et des belles choses les
progrès de la science les progressions
de la médecine c'est des bonnes choses
et de faire des suv
c'est pas forcément souhaitable voyez
c'est pas parce que c'est une usine et
bien que pour des malades de cancer par
exemple et pour les voilà si cette
technologie est un progrès mais ce que
j'allais vous fait dire c'est que
exactement il aller d'un point a à un
point b
c'est ça le progrès mais la question
c'est quel point b on veut quel mode de
société on veut est ce qu'on veut une
société où on peut se vivre et
s'épanouir sans détruire la planète est
d'ailleurs sans détruire aussi les
relations humaines parce que je n'en ont
plus que tout fonctionne bien avec les
inégalités aujourd'hui et dans ce cas là
oui une fois qu'on est défini le projet
de société politiquement on s'intéresse
à comment on y va et la technologie peut
nous y amener et pour les progrès
médicaux mais évidemment qu'on va faire
des conneries mais ce que dit monsieur
alexandre c'est pas ça et dit allons-y à
fond dans la technologie il dit aussi
que pour des questions de compétitivité
et pour des questions sociales il
parlait des gilet jaune privé la france
de cette technologie nous déclasserait
et aurait des conséquences sur le
pouvoir d'achat sur sur la vie
quotidienne des français mais ça si vous
voulez que je sache on vit dans un très
technologique sap a réduit les
inégalités
la technologie ne réduit pas les
inégalités ce qui va réduire les
inégalités c'est un projet politique
c'est la redistribution c'est le partage
c'est une forme de sobriété
c'est aussi le numérique a quand même
permis un certain donald confinement et
je suis bien content que je suis pas en
train de s'affirmer numérique et c'est
le diable de m on vous dit que dépassée
à x 100 en vitesse de numérique pour des
raisons écologiques d'ailleurs on parle
du co2 on parle aussi de tous les
appareils qui vont être obsolète
s'appelle l'obsolescence programmée
on prévoit déjà donc là dans les années
qui viennent de jeter vos 34 millions de
smartphones parce qu'ils ne serviront
plus à rien a lâché la planète comment
on peut enfin on peut être pour la
technologie mais comment on peut être
pour ce sac à chaud face à la la la je
vous avoue je décroche à rester avec
nous parce qu'un autre sujet concernant
7,5 g c'est cette guerre technologique
presqu'une une guerre d'espionnage on
pourrait dire qui est en train de se
jouer entre les etats-unis et la chine
françois durpaire explique et nous cette
guéguerre entre trump et sismique
voilà en fait c'est pas un autre sujet
c'est le sujet pour faire la transition
on pourrait dire qu'effectivement
il me dit ce qui serait souhaitable ce
qui serait souhaitable quand il ya une
nouvelle technologie aussi importante
que celle là c'est de prendre son temps
pour se dire qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
ça et comment on la maîtrise et puis
laurent alexandre dit voilà ce qu'est en
train de se passer et en particulier
qu'est ce qui est en train de se passer
entre les états unis et la chine
mais c'est le sort de la première
puissance mondiale
c'est dire que les etats-unis se disent
aujourd'hui est bien la chine si la
chine est leader sur la 5g et bien c'est
elle qui déterminera quelle sera
l'économie de demain puisque la 4g la
kadji c'était avec ces nouvelles voies
comme vous le dites c'était un certain
nombre de baisses étaient netflix s'est
tellement l'économie d'aujourd'hui 1er
bis nbi enfin tout ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui
mais vous imaginez les voitures
autonomes demain donc trump il dit deux
choses il y effectivement j'interdis à
mes entreprises d'utiliser cette
technologie chinoise parce que c'est un
enjeu nationaliste j'ai fait mon slogan
sur mac america great games il faut
absolument pas que les chinois de 2000
dans ce domaine et puis il ya
effectivement c'est en jeu d'espionnage
c'est à dire celui qui maîtrise à singer
il maîtrise toutes les données du monde
la circulation de toutes les
informations du monde donc c'est même
pas de laisser de l'espionnage si vous
voulez à l'échelle de la planète et qui
maîtrise le savoir maîtrise le pouvoir
donc c'est en quelque sorte si vous
voulez le sort en fait des années qui
viennent qui se détermine à travers ce
qui est même au delà d'une technologie
ce qui en fait est le monde de demain
alors dans ce monde de demain laurent
alexandre ou est-ce que vous vous situez
est-ce qu'on a raison de s'inquiéter
d'une d'un potentiel espionnage chinois
à travers la 5g alors le spina chinois
via les antennes huawai personnellement
je n'y crois pas beaucoup en revanche
qu'il y à une guerre technologique sur
la 5g sur le numérique sur l'ordinateur
quantique et l'intelligence artificielle
entre la chine et les etats unis c'est
évident ce qui se joue en ce moment
c'est qui sera la première puissance
mondiale
votre invité l'a parfaitement expliqué à
l'instant et si l'europe sort de cette
bataille technologique et refuse cette
bataille technologique
elle va être comme les pays qui n'ont
pas
lui le train en 1881 ils sont devenus
les pays sous-développés du 20e siècle
donc si l'europe loupé le coche excusez
moi de le dire à votre invité
écologistes mais l'europe ce sera le
zimbabwe de 2100 nous serons un
continent totalement sous développée par
ailleurs on a parlé tout à l'heure
d'empreinte écologique on oublie de dire
que dans un pays comme la france ou la
quasi totalité de l'électricité et des
carbonnais grâce au nucléaire
les écologistes n'ayant pas encore
réussi à faire fermer toutes les
centrales nucléaires
ils n'ont fermé que fessenheim pour
l'instant l'empreinte co2 delà de la 5g
est extrêmement faible puisque en france
l'électricité produite six fois moins de
co2 comme un gant en allemagne grâce
grâce au nucléaire donc il n'ya pas de
problème écologique avec la 5g dans les
faits il est arrivé comme la france et
il y à une nécessité de se battre dans
cette grande bataille technologique du
21e siècle pour éviter que nos enfants
et nos petits-enfants vivent dans un
pays sous développé à la fin du siège on
a bien compris le message merci beaucoup
laurent alexandre vous aurez le mot de
la fin vous avez une petite minute à
peine à peine 30 secondes pour conclure
qu'ils veulent à saint gilles en vérité
je vais vous dire c'est les gars femmes
et les constructeurs nouveau une
automobile pourquoi pour numériser
encore plus votre vie avoir le plus
d'écrans de temps de d'attention
derrière l'écran et vous savez à la cie
caudeval et les amis de monsieur
alexandre leurs enfants il les met dans
des écoles sans internet et sans écran
aussi se poser la question allait bien
on s'arrête on s'arrête là de toute
façon on n'y est pas encore même si le
gouvernement a donné les licences à la
5g avec vont chez toi jeune de avec m
avec des conditions et notamment des
conditions de temps merci beaucoup
impressionné de voir sur le plateau des
tp c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de nous avoir suivis et à demain très
belle soirée
[Musique]